This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In October 1967, the world's greatest chess minds gathered in Seuss, Tunisia, to face off at the interzonal tournament, the high-stakes gateway to the World Chess Championship. The early games were dominated by the American prodigy, Bobby Fisher. He was a 24-year-old grandmaster with an IQ rumor to be at the genius level of 180. He was the favorite to win it all. But despite his overwhelming lead, the tournament quickly spiraled into a masterclass in self-sabotage. Bobby Fisher issued a series of escalating demands regarding his playing schedule.
这里是隐藏的大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。1967年10月，世界顶尖的国际象棋大师们聚集在突尼斯苏斯，参加洲际锦标赛，这是通往世界国际象棋锦标赛的高风险关口。比赛早期由美国天才少年鲍比·费舍尔主导。他是一位24岁的特级大师，据传智商高达180的天才水平。他是赢得一切的热门人选。但尽管他占据压倒性优势，锦标赛很快就演变成了一场自我破坏的大师课。鲍比·费舍尔对他的比赛赛程提出了一系列升级的要求。
When organizers refused to rearrange the event to suit him, he walked out, withdrawing from the tournament while in first place, and throwing away years of work in a single fit of frustration. The walkout was a window into a profound emotional ineptness that lived right alongside Bobby Fisher's brilliance. Throughout his career, he operated in a state of constant relational friction, alienating the very coaches and friends who try to support him. At his chess matches, he frequently violated the social norms of the game, arriving late and refusing to make eye contact with the player sitting across from him.
当组织者拒绝重新安排赛事来迎合他时，他一走了之，在处于第一名的时候退出了比赛，在一时沮丧中扔掉了多年的心血。这次罢赛让我们得以一窥鲍比·费舍尔辉煌背后的巨大情感无能。在他的整个职业生涯中，他一直处于持续的人际摩擦状态中，疏远了那些试图支持他的教练和朋友。在他的国际象棋比赛中，他经常违反这项运动的社交规范，迟到并拒绝与坐在对面的选手进行眼神交流。
Bobby Fisher possessed a mind that could see a dozen moves ahead on a chess board, but he struggled with the basic moves of social and emotional life. This week on Hidden Brain and in a companion episode on Hidden Brain Plus, the logic of emotion and how feelings make us smarter. Think back to the last time you made a decision you regret it. Perhaps you felt blinded by rage or paralyzed by fear. In those moments, it feels like our emotions are obstacles to our success, a vestige of our primitive brains getting in a moment.
鲍比·费舍尔拥有一颗能在棋盘上预见十多步的大脑，但他却在社交和情感生活的基本动作上举步维艰。本周的“隐藏大脑”以及“隐藏大脑Plus”的配套节目将探讨情感逻辑以及情感如何让我们变得更聪明。回想一下你上次做出后悔决定的情景。也许你曾觉得被愤怒蒙蔽双眼，或是被恐惧吓得瘫痪。在那些时刻，我们感觉自己的情感是成功的阻碍，是我们原始大脑残余的影响。
in the way of our rational minds. But research in recent decades into the world of emotions suggests that this idea is profoundly wrong. Emotions are central to our ability to understand, attend, and to prioritize. They aren't obstacles that block our path. They are food and fuel for the journey. Peter Salovey is a psychologist at Yale University.
阻碍了我们的理性思维。但近几十年来对情感世界的研究所表明，这种观点是大错特错的。情感对于我们理解、关注和确定优先级的核心能力至关重要。它们不是阻挡我们道路的障碍。它们是这段旅程的养分和燃料。彼得·萨洛维是耶鲁大学的心理学家。
He studies how our emotions shape our decisions and our behavior. Peter Salove, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much, Shankar. It's a real honor to be with you. I listen to your show regularly and I've enjoyed seeing you live as well. And so it's a privilege to be a guest. Peter, in addition to being a psychology professor at Yale,
他研究我们的情感如何塑造我们的决策和行为。彼得·萨洛维，欢迎来到“隐藏大脑”。非常感谢，尚卡尔。能和你在一起真是我的荣幸。我经常收听你的节目，我也很喜欢看你的现场演出。所以能作为嘉宾是一种特权。彼得，除了担任耶鲁大学的心理学教授之外，
you've held several administrative posts at the university, including Provost and Dean. While you were dean, a prominent individual visited the campus. Can you paint me a picture of the moment you got to shake hands with the president? Yes, we had invited President Clinton to visit campus. And if memory serves, he was going to give a talk on campus at the time. And they lined all of us up, all the deans in the boardroom, actually, of the university. when you were around the perimeter
你还在大学担任过几个行政职务，包括教务长和院长。在你担任院长期间，一位杰出的个人访问了校园。你能描绘一下你和总统握手的那一刻的画面吗？是的，我们曾邀请克林顿总统访问校园。如果记忆准确的话，他当时将在校园发表演讲。他们让我们所有人，所有的院长都排成一队，实际上是在大学的董事会议室里，当时你们在四周
and President Clinton walked in. And he worked his way around the perimeter of the room, shaking hands with everyone. And when he got to me, I was quite nervous, actually. And he stuck out his hands and he said, I'm Bill Clinton. And I said, I'm Peter Salve.
克林顿总统走了进来。他绕着房间的四周走，和每个人握手。当他走到我面前时，其实我相当紧张。他伸出手说，我是比尔·克林顿。我说，我是彼得·萨洛维。
I'm the dean of Yale College. And he said, you know, it's a pleasure to meet you, Peter. we actually already know each other. So when he said that you had met earlier, had you actually met him earlier, Peter? No, I had never met him, at least, you know, not to my memory, but no, no, I had never met him. I had never met him.
我是耶鲁学院的院长。他说，很高兴见到你，彼得。其实我们已经认识了。所以当他说你们之前见过面时，彼得，你们真的以前见过面吗？不，我从没见过他，至少，你知道的，在我记忆中没有，不，不，我从没见过他。我从未见过他。
And so I was surprised when he said that. And, of course, I was a little nervous. Like, am I forget that I had met Bill Clinton? How could that possibly be? So I'm a little self-conscious in my interaction. at that point. So something happened earlier that day that is pertinent to what Bill Clinton told you. Tell me what happened earlier that morning, Peter.
所以当他这么说时我很惊讶。当然，我有点紧张。就像，我难道忘记了自己见过比尔·克林顿吗？怎么可能发生这种事？所以在那个互动时刻，我有点自我意识过强。所以那天早些时候发生了一件事，与比尔·克林顿对你所说的话有关。彼得，告诉我那天早上早些时候发生了什么。
Yeah, so as I was coming on campus, really, to park near where this meet and greet was going to take place, I saw a spot, I pulled in quickly, and I didn't realize it, but I had pulled right in front of Bill Clinton's limo. and, in fact, kind of cut it off. And a Secret Service agent or some kind of security that was with him jumped out of the car and said, hey, wait, wait, wait, wait. And President Clinton rolled the window down and said, no, no, no, no, it's okay. That guy's the dean. And I realized he had been reviewing the people he was going to meet
是的，当我来到校园时，准确地说，是为了停在这场见面会附近，我看到一个车位，迅速把车开了进去，我当时没意识到，但我直接把车停在了比尔·克林顿的豪华轿车前面，事实上，有点挡住了它。和他一起的一名特工或某种安保人员从车里跳出来说，嘿，等等，等等，等等，等等。克林顿总统摇下车窗说，不，不，不，不，没关系。那家伙是院长。我意识到他一直在回顾他将要见面的人
in his car, most likely, as a public figure might. And so when I was in the meet-and-greet line to meet him, he said to me, we already know each other. And I was so charmed by this. And more importantly, he could tell I was nervous. You could tell I was anxious meeting the president. And he told that story to sort of say, there's no need to be nervous, Mr. Dean. We're old friends. We had an interaction earlier today. It put me at ease. It was a wonderful example of President Clinton managing my emotions. He can see I'm nervous. No need to be nervous.
在车里，很有可能是作为一个公众人物可能会做的那样。所以当我在见面会排队见他时，他对我说，我们已经认识了。我对此感到非常着迷。更重要的是，他看得出我很紧张。你一眼就能看出我见总统时很焦虑。他讲这个故事可以说是为了说明，没有必要紧张，院长先生。我们是老朋友了。我们今天早些时候有过互动。这让我放松了下来。这是克林顿总统管理我情绪的一个绝佳例子。他能看出我很紧张。没必要紧张。
We're old friends, he says. And in fact, the old friends is based on an embarrassing interaction, but that doesn't matter. I've seen photographs of the moment. He's looking me in the eye and giving me a firm handshake. And it's that when he's looking at me, he is seeing that I have a look of nervousness or fear, anxiety in my face. And it cues him to do something, which is tell this story about the interaction with him and his limo and the Secret Service because he knows it might put me at ease. So it makes us feel familiar and like old.
他说，我们是老朋友。事实上，“老朋友”是基于一次尴尬的互动，但这没关系。我见过那一刻的照片。他正看着我的眼睛，给我一个坚定的握手。正因为他在看着我，他看到我的脸上有一种紧张、恐惧或焦虑的表情。这提示他做一件事，那就是讲这个关于他、他的豪华轿车和特工之间互动的故事，因为他知道这可能会让我放松。所以这让我们感到熟悉，就像老朋友一样。
old friends. What Peter realized after the fact was that Bill Clinton had demonstrated an essential idea in Peter's own research. Some people are incredibly skilled at reading a room. In interactions with others, this gives them an edge.
彼得事后意识到的是，比尔·克林顿展示了彼得自己研究中的一个核心观点。有些人极其擅长解读房间里的氛围。在与他人的交往中，这赋予了他们优势。
They can see around the corners of a conversation, soothe frictions, put people at ease. Some years after this incident, Peter became a president himself. He became president of Yale. He inherited a challenge that required the same skills of him that Bill Clinton had shown in that interaction.
他们能够看透谈话的拐角，化解摩擦，让人放松。在这起事件几年后，彼得自己也成为了一名校长。他成为了耶鲁大学的校长。他继承了一个挑战，这需要他展现出比尔·克林顿在那次互动中表现出的相同技能。
We had a residential college named for John C. Calhoun. It's called Calhoun College. John C. Calhoun was a senator, was the vice president of the United States, all before the Civil War, served as, I think, Secretary of State and Secretary of War as well. But what he was most well known for is he was. his ardent defense of slavery. Slavery not just as a, quote, way of life in the South, but to use his words as a positive good. He believed, and he rooted it in white supremacy,
我们有一个以约翰·C·卡尔霍恩命名的住宿学院。它叫卡尔霍恩学院。约翰·C·卡尔霍恩曾任参议员、美国副总统，这一切都发生在内战之前，我还认为他曾担任国务卿和战争部长。但他最广为人知的是他对奴隶制的狂热辩护。奴隶制不仅被视为南方的一种生活方式，用他的话说，更是一种“积极的好事”。他相信这一点，并将其根植于白人至上主义中，
he viewed it as the proper order of society. And I imagine he must have gone to Yale himself if a building was named after him. Yeah, he'd been vice president of the United States. He was a Yale graduate. And when the building was built in about 1930, there was a debate about who to name it for. And there were two colleges being named that year. And they named one of the colleges after a minister.
他认为这是社会的正确秩序。我想如果有一栋建筑以他的名字命名，他自己一定去过耶鲁大学吧。是的，他曾任美国副总统。他是耶鲁大学的毕业生。当这栋建筑在大约1930年建造时，曾关于以谁的名字命名它进行过辩论。当年有两所学院在命名。他们以一位牧师的名字命名了其中一所学院。
And so the other was to be named after the most prominent statesman who at the time would have been Johnson Calhoun. So with that as history, over the years, many decades, there had been more and less protest about this name. Why do we name a college after the most ardent defender of slavery? And so I, in some ways, tired of receiving petitions about this or watching protest, I said, let's have a conversation. And I gave my welcoming speech that fall. And I said, let's have the kind of conversations you should have on campus about whether we should continue to have a college named for John C. C. C. C. C. C. C.ohun? And I made the argument that good people, moral people, thoughtful people would likely find themselves on both sides of this issue. some wanting change, some saying we don't need to honor John C. C. C. C. Cohen. And others saying, we may not agree with John C. Cohen. But he's a public figure, a historic figure. And universities should not be in the business of effacing history.
因此另一所将以当时最杰出的政治家命名，即约翰·C·卡尔霍恩。带着这段历史，在过去的几十年里，关于这个名字的抗议时多时少。为什么我们要以奴隶制的狂热捍卫者的名字来命名一所学院？因此，我某种程度上厌倦了收到关于此事的请愿书或观看抗议活动，我说，让我们进行一次对话。我在那年秋天发表了欢迎辞。我说，让我们在校园里进行应有的对话，讨论我们是否应该继续保留一个以约翰·C·卡尔霍恩命名的学院？我提出这样的观点：好人、道德高尚的人、有思想的人很可能会发现自己站在这个问题的两边。一些人想要改变，一些人说我们不需要纪念约翰·C·卡尔霍恩。而另一些人则说，我们可能不同意约翰·C·卡尔霍恩的观点。但他是一个公众人物、历史人物。大学不应该做抹去历史的事。
So early on, as this controversy was brewing, you decided that the name should not be changed. Talk about it. about the moment you actually announced this to the campus and what the reaction was, Peter? Sure. While our students generally wanted the name to be changed, our alumni did not, and our faculty at that point were largely not interested in this particular issue. And I talked to many experts, the head of the NACP, prominent African-Americans. American intellectuals who had lived in Calhoun College when they were Yale undergraduates and many, many others. And all of them were profoundly ambivalent about the idea of effacing history. We should leave his name on there.
因此，在这场争议酝酿的早期，你决定不应该更改名字。彼得，谈谈你实际向校园宣布这一决定的那一刻以及反应如何？当然。虽然我们的学生普遍希望改名，但我们的校友不希望，而当时的教职员工对这个特定问题基本上不感兴趣。我同许多专家交谈过，包括全国有色人种协进会负责人、杰出的非裔美国人。作为耶鲁本科生时曾住在卡尔霍恩学院的美国知识分子以及许许多多其他人。他们所有人对抹去历史的想法都感到深深的矛盾。我们应该把他的名字留在那里。
Many of them said, but confront him in other ways. And so in light of that, I had announced that we would maintain the name, but we would contextualize it. We would put up educational materials, plaques and the like, explaining who he was and what he believed and why we left his name on the college. Well, I think the next day after announcing that decision, there was a very loud protest on campus, led by students. We had a town hall meeting at which I spoke, and now the faculty were quite energized by the issue. I think seeing how upset the students were, they were then called. for a different outcome. I understand that during the town hall,
他们中的许多人说，但要以其他方式与他面对面。鉴于此，我宣布我们将保留该名字，但我们会将其置于特定背景下。我们将设立教育材料、牌匾等，解释他是谁、他信仰什么以及为什么我们把他的名字留在学院里。嗯，我想在宣布该决定后的第二天，校园里爆发了一场由学生领导的非常响亮的抗议。我们举行了一场市政厅会议，我在会上发言了，现在教职员工对这个问题相当兴奋。我认为看到学生们如此沮丧，他们随后呼吁了不同的结果。据我了解，在市政厅会议期间，
there was a moment when students were showering you with fake cash to make the assertion that you cared more about, you know, donors and the alumni than the well-being of students. And that must have come as something of a shock to you. That, of course, was a shock to me. You know, I was a very student-oriented president. I taught students,
有一个时刻，学生们向你抛洒假现金，以此断言你更关心的是捐赠者和校友，而不是学生的福祉。那对你来说一定是一个相当大的打击。那对我来说当然是一个打击。你知道，我是一个非常以学生为本的校长。我教过学生，
introductory psychology for many, many, many years. And so I was not happy about that kind of protest. Several months later, in the summer, a worker in Calhoun College, I believe he was a dining hall worker, noticed that the iconography, the symbolism, the windows, stained glass windows in Calhoun College reflected themes relevant to the name. They reflected the Old South, African Americans picking cotton. John C. Calhoun is kind of a statesman looking regal. And he, in a kind of emotional moment, he broke one of these stained glass windows, I believe it was the one of the African Americans picking cotton. And he said that as a black man,
多年来一直教授基础心理学。所以对于那种抗议我并不高兴。几个月后的夏天，卡尔霍恩学院的一名员工，我相信他是一名食堂员工，注意到卡尔霍恩学院的图像学、象征意义、窗户、彩色玻璃窗反映了与这个名字相关的主题。它们反映了美国旧南方，非裔美国人在采棉花。约翰·C·卡尔霍恩像是一个威严的政治家。而且他，在一种情绪化的时刻，打破了其中一扇彩色玻璃窗，我相信是那扇描绘非裔美国人采棉花的窗户。他说作为一个黑人，
I couldn't stand looking at that every day. And I needed to do something. I'm wondering, Peter, as you heard about all this protest and you saw how intense the feelings were, did you have a moment when you felt that you had in some ways misjudged the intensity, the depth of feelings that existed on campus about this issue? Yes, and I think part of that was
我每天看着那个简直无法忍受。我需要做点什么。彼得，我想知道，当你听到所有这些抗议并看到情绪是多么强烈时，你有没有某一刻觉得自己在某种程度上误判了校园里关于这个问题的激烈程度和情感深度？是的，我认为部分原因是
that times were changing. This was all happening in a dynamic environment. It was happening in real time. And I think when we began this conversation, sure, students wanted change. But many other people, quite reasonably, made the argument that a facing history was not appropriate. I think views shifted over the course of that year.
时代在变。这一切都发生在一个动态的环境中。它正在实时发生。我认为当我们开始这场对话时，当然，学生们想要改变。但许多其他人相当合理地提出论点，认为抹去历史是不合适的。我认为在这期间大家的观点发生了转变。
And in the course of grappling with my own feelings about that, I met with an African-American student who grew up in South Carolina. In fact, she grew up, I believe, in a home just off of Calhoun Street in Charleston. This student said to me something very interesting. She said, I've known the name of Calhoun all my life. I know who he is. I can handle being in a space named for John C. Calvin, such as Calhoun College. But I don't want to live in a shrine to slavery. And I said, that's a powerful metaphor.
在我努力处理自己对此类情感的过程中，我遇到了一位在南卡罗来纳州长大的非裔美国学生。事实上，我相信她是在查尔斯顿卡尔霍恩街旁的一所房子里长大的。这个学生对我说了一件非常有趣的事。她说，我一辈子都知道卡尔霍恩的名字。我知道他是谁。我可以忍受身处一个以约翰·C·卡尔霍恩命名的空间，比如卡尔霍恩学院。但我不想生活在一个奴隶制的圣地里。我说，这是一个有力的隐喻。
What do you mean by that? She goes, look at the stained glass windows. Look at the reliefs carved into the stone walls. Look at the artifact. from plantations in the south that are in the collection of this college. Look at the name that is on our t-shirts when we go out and play intramural sports. This has become a shrine to slavery. And I swallowed hard.
你这话是什么意思？她说，看看那些彩色玻璃窗。看看雕刻在石墙上的浮雕。看看来自南方种植园的文物，它们是这个学院收藏的一部分。看看当我们出去打校内体育比赛时T恤上的名字。这里已经变成了一个奴隶制的圣地。我艰难地咽了口唾沫。
And I had a moment of emotional understanding and deep empathy that the debate really wasn't entirely about do you honor figures from the past, even if we completely disavow their viewpoints now, or whether you efface history, or whether times change and who we honor should change. I suddenly got focused on how people feel. thinking about that student living in a shrine to slavery, thinking about our worker so moved to an act of vandalism, that he risked his job, he risked criminal prosecution. It was a shift in my thinking. And it was really a processing of those emotions.
我经历了一个情感理解和深切同理心的时刻，意识到这场辩论实际上并不完全在于你是否应该纪念过去的人物，即使我们现在完全否认他们的观点，或者你是否应该抹去历史，或者时代是否变了以及我们应该纪念谁应该改变。我突然专注于人们的感受。想到那个生活在奴隶制圣地里的学生，想到我们的员工如此深受触动以至于做出破坏行为，他冒着失去工作的风险，冒着面临刑事起诉的风险。我的思维发生了转变。这确实是对这些情感的加工，
triggered by my interaction with the student primarily, that created a moment of clarity for me and suggested that we needed to consider an alternative path. What did you end up doing? We ended up changing the name. The name of that college is Grace Hopper College, named after early computer scientist, I think before the field had even been invented.
主要是由我与学生的互动引发的，这为我创造了一个清晰的时刻，并表明我们需要考虑一条替代道路。你最后做了什么？我们最终改名了。那个学院的名字叫格蕾丝·霍珀学院，以一位早期计算机科学家命名，我想当时这个领域甚至还没有被发明出来，
and a Navy Admiral. But we honored her service and being one of the early founders of the field. She had gotten her PhD in mathematics at Yale. But it was really this moment of insight created by the arousal of empathy following an emotional conversation with a student that set me anyway on a different course in my thinking. One of the most consequential challenges we face in daily life is to read what is happening in the emotional lives of other people. When we come back, how the ability to read the emotional undercurrents in a room can transform our lives.
她还是一位海军上将。但我们纪念她的服务，以及她是该领域的早期奠基人之一。她在耶鲁获得了数学博士学位。但真正让我走上不同思维轨道的是，在与学生进行了一次情感对话后，由激发同理心所产生的一瞬洞察力。我们在日常生活中面临的最重大挑战之一，是解读其他人情感生活中正在发生的事情。当我们回来时，解读房间里情感暗流的能力如何能够改变我们的生活。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Schools and universities often test students on their knowledge of complex material. In the workplace, employees are promoted because of their expertise and problem-solving skills. We've all heard of geniuses who produce great works of literature or magnificent musical compositions. But dig a layer deeper, and you find that some of the smartest people are not very smart when it comes to gauging the emotional temperature of a situation. When they meet someone new, they find it hard to tell friend from foe,
你正在收听的是“隐藏大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是隐藏大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。学校和大学经常测试学生对复杂材料的知识掌握情况。在职场中，员工因其专业知识和解决问题能力而得到晋升。我们都听说过能够创作伟大文学作品或宏伟音乐作品的天才。但再深入挖掘一层，你会发现一些最聪明的人在衡量某种情况的情感温度时其实并不那么聪明。当他们遇到新面孔时，他们很难分辨敌友，
They are unaware of the emotional undercurrent swirling around them, and they often behave like bulls in China shops. Peter Salivay is a psychologist at Yale University. He studies how our emotions shape our decisions and our behavior. Peter, your research tackles a longstanding belief of Western culture that thinking and feeling are opposing forces in the mind. Talk a moment about the long history of that idea. Yes. Whether you're looking at, you know, stoic philosophers or many religious traditions and the like,
他们没有意识到周围涌动的情感暗流，而且他们的行为往往像瓷器店里的公牛。彼得·萨洛维是耶鲁大学的心理学家。他研究我们的情感如何塑造我们的决策和行为。彼得，你的研究打破了西方文化长期以来认为思维和情感是头脑中对立力量的信念。请谈谈这种观念的悠久历史。是的。无论你是在审视，你知道的，斯多葛学派哲学家还是许多宗教传统等等
the idea is that we shouldn't be ruled by our passions. You know, rule your feelings or your feelings will rule you. It's kind of the idea that on the one hand, we have thought and reason, and on the other, we have emotions, passions. The belief was somehow that our emotions were vestigial, meaning, yes, they're part of our animal heritage, just like our wisdom teeth, just like our appendices. But we don't really need them anymore. We are a thinking species. Peter and a colleague, Jack Mayer,
核心观点是我们不应该被激情所支配。你知道的，要么你驾驭情绪，要么情绪驾驭你。这种观点大致是：一方面，我们有思想和理性；另一方面，我们有情感和激情。过去的看法在某种程度上认为情感是退化的产物，意思是说，是的，它们是我们动物祖先遗留的一部分，就像我们的智齿一样，就像我们的阑尾一样。但我们其实已经不再需要它们了。我们是一个会思考的物种。彼得和同事杰克·迈尔，
noticed there were all kinds of situations where people are asked to read the emotional temperature of a situation. Some people are better at doing this than others. wasn't this a kind of intelligence too, they wondered? Together, they came up with a formulation for the skill they were talking about. They called it emotional intelligence. The idea came to them in the oddest of places, not a lab, but as the two were painting Peter's living room.
注意到有各种各样的情况，人们需要去解读某种情境下的情绪温度。有些人比其他人更擅长这样做。他们不禁琢磨，这难道也是一种智力吗？他们共同为所讨论的这种技能提出了一种表述方式。他们称之为情商。这个想法在一个最意想不到的地方萌生了——不是在实验室里，而是当这两人粉刷彼得的客厅时。
Yeah, that is what happened, and we're painting the living room, we're talking about emotions, we're talking about intelligence. We both had done research on the impact of mood and emotion on memory, on judgment, on decision-making, and we were just chatting as we painted. Jack was very nice to help me paint my living, and we'd only been friends a year or two at that point, and talked about this idea of emotional intelligence. My original idea was let's develop a framework
是的，事情就是这样的。我们在粉刷客厅，我们在谈论情绪，我们在谈论智力。我们俩之前都做过关于心境和情绪对记忆、判断以及决策影响的研究，我们在粉刷的时候就顺便聊了起来。杰克人非常好，主动来帮我粉刷客厅，那时我们认识也就一两年吧，我们就聊到了情商这个概念。我最初的想法是让我们开发一个框架，
for organizing all of these abilities having to do with the emotions and their effect on thinking and behavior. Jack came out of a more traditional, intelligence laboratory, but had now turned his attention to mood and emotion. And he was wondering whether you could measure any of this. And so we came together in that way. Yes, and it was while painting my house. Peter and his colleagues have found ways to measure emotional intelligence. Instead of asking people about their emotional skills, people turn out to be poor judges of their own emotional intelligence, the researchers came up with a series of tests.
用来系统整理所有这些与情绪以及情绪对思维和行为影响相关的能力。杰克来自一个更传统的智力实验室，但当时已经将注意力转向了心境和情绪。他想知道是否有可能对这些东西进行测量。我们就这样走到了一起。是的，就是在粉刷我房子的时候。彼得和他的同事们找到了测量情商的方法。研究人员没有直接询问人们的情绪技能（事实证明人们并不善于准确评估自己的情商），而是设计了一系列测试。
How good were people at reading the expressions of others? How well did they understand what was happening in their own emotional lives? How skillful were they at regulating their emotions? They came up with a measure, very much like an IQ test. It came to be called the Mayor Salovee-Carruso scale, or Mesquite, for short. We did a study in which you came to the lab as a participant in research and had to interact with a stranger and then the stranger would rate how well did you listen to him
人们解读他人表情的能力有多强？他们对自己情感生活中发生的事情理解得有多深？他们在调节情绪方面有多熟练？他们设计了一种测量方法，非常类似于智商测试。它后来被称为“迈尔-萨洛维-卡鲁索量表”，简称Mesquite。我们做过一项研究，你作为研究参与者来到实验室，必须与一个陌生人互动，然后由陌生人来评判你倾听他说话的程度有多高，
how connected were you trying to be with him how empathic did you seem and for our participants who scored well on the mesquite, the stranger rated them more highly. But also, we could show videos of that interaction to others, who had no idea, of course, what the experiment really was about, and they rated the person as more sociable,
你当时有多努力想与他建立联系，你看起来表现得有多同理心。对于那些在Mesquite测试中得分较高的参与者，陌生人给他们的评价更高。不仅如此，我们还可以把这种互动的视频展示给其他人，当然，他们并不知道实验的真实目的，而他们也将这个人评为更具社交能力、
better able to make friends and the like, if they had higher scores. We could also do just correlational studies. How many friends do you have? It's predicted by the mesquite, by our emotional intelligence measure. Do you engage in pro-social behaviors with friends? Are you more likely to help, to share, or are you more likely to get into arguments and fights? All of it predicted by emotional intelligence.
如果他们得分较高，他们就更善于交朋友之类的事情。我们还可以做纯粹的相关性研究。你有多少朋友？这可以通过Mesquite、通过我们的情商测量来预测。你是否会和朋友一起参与亲社会行为？你更有可能去帮助别人、分享，还是更容易卷入争吵和打架？所有这一切都可以由情商来预测。
So I'm sure everyone listening knows of someone who everyone wants to be their friend because they listen well, they empathize, they reflect feelings. They seem to be able to pick up on something about you that many others don't. And they seem to be able to kind of walk a mile in your shoes. And not surprisingly, they are the kinds of individuals who you would love to have as a friend. You've also looked at how emotional intelligence makes a difference in other realms of life. young people who are more emotionally intelligent tend to be less likely to engage in risky behaviors.
所以，我确信所有听众都认识这样一个人：大家都想和他们做朋友，因为他们善解人意、富有同理心、能够呼应别人的情感。他们似乎能捕捉到许多人察觉不到的关于你的一些特质。而且他们似乎能够设身处地为你着想。毫无疑问，他们正是那种你很渴望拥有作朋友的人。你们还研究了情商如何在生活的其他领域发挥作用。更具情商的年轻人往往不那么容易从事高风险行为。
Why do you think this might be the case, Peter? Yeah, that's right. We've shown correlations between mesquite scores and the likelihood of using drugs or alcohol, particularly in adolescence. Higher scores on the mesquite predict less likelihood of drug or alcohol use, less likelihood of delinquent behavior.
彼得，你认为这可能是为什么呢？是的，确实如此。我们已经证明了Mesquite得分与吸毒或酗酒可能性之间的相关性，尤其是在青春期。Mesquite得分较高预示着吸毒或酗酒的可能性较小，出现不良行为的可能性也较小。
I think some of it is, you know, if you're more in touch with your own emotions, you don't need, what would I say, illicit substances to help you regulate them? You're less likely to need to self-medicate. Similarly, if you're better able to empathize, better able to understand the emotions of another person,
我想其中一部分原因在于，你知道的，如果你对自己的情绪有更深的感知，你就不需要——我该怎么说呢——不需要借助违禁物质来帮你调节情绪？你不太需要通过药物来进行自我治疗。同样地，如果你更有同理心，更能理解另一个人的情绪，
you're less likely to have conflict with them, less likely to think the way to settle differences is through fighting. Maybe most importantly, you're more likely as a kid to stay in school because you like school and you like learning better. So I think it's all of a piece, right? You're happier in the school environment, more likely to make friends, less likely to become frustrated, drop out, more likely to not self-medicate with drugs or alcohol when you get older.
你与他们发生冲突的可能性就会降低，觉得通过打架来解决分歧的想法也会减少。也许最重要的是，作为孩子，你更有可能留在学校，因为你更喜欢学校，也更喜欢学习。所以我觉得这一切都是连贯的，对吧？你在学校环境中更快乐，更容易交到朋友，更不容易感到沮丧而辍学，当你长大后，也更不容易用毒品或酒精来进行自我治疗。
It's all of a piece. And this is not just when you are looking at the behavior of students and young people. You find emotional intelligence plays a role in our work lives. For sure. One small study we did was at an insurance company where we measured traditional intelligence. We measured personality. And we also gave them a skee, or measure of emotional intelligence. And what we predicted a time later,
这一切都是相互关联的。而且这不仅体现在观察学生和年轻人的行为时。你会发现情商在我们的职场生活中也扮演着重要角色。确实如此。我们做过的一项小型研究是在一家保险公司，我们测量了传统智力，测量了人格，还给他们做了Mesquite测试，也就是情商测量。后来我们预测的是，
were the performance reviews you received from your boss and whether you were likely to get a promotion and how big a raise that you received at work. But the emotional intelligence test that we used, the mesquite was a good predictor of those kinds of workplace outcomes. People who are better able to regulate their own emotions were at a huge advantage in the workplace. You've written and talked quite a bit about what
你在工作中从老板那里得到的绩效评估，你是否有可能获得晋升，以及你在工作中获得了多大幅度的加薪。而我们使用的情商测试——Mesquite，是预测这些职场结果的良好指标。那些更善于调节自己情绪的人在职场中享有巨大的优势。你写过也谈论过很多关于
an emotionally intelligent manager looks like, Peter. What are the qualities of individuals in the workplace? And what are they able to do in their interactions with others? So the emotionally intelligent manager, they recognize what might be going on in a situation beyond what people are simply saying. They recognize that somebody might be saying one thing but feeling another and that that needs to be explored
一个高情商的管理者是什么样子的，彼得。职场中这样的人有哪些特质？他们在与他人互动时能够做到什么？所以，高情商的管理者，他们能够识别出人们表面言语背后可能正在发生的事情。他们认识到某人可能嘴上说着一套，心里想的却是另一套，而这一点需要进行深入探索，
in depth. But I could tell you a story. In early days, David Caruso and I were doing some training at a large investment bank. And this was before the Great Recession. And this was a bank that was quite affected by the Great Recession. And these were essentially vice presidents and senior vice presidents, engaged in banking, engaged in trading, engaged in providing investment advice, and the like. And only 10% of them or so were going to be promoted to their ultimate goal, which was to become a managing director, which is where much more serious compensation is received. And so we would ask at the beginning of our conversation, at the beginning of our sessions,
深入探讨。不过我可以给你讲个故事。在早期，大卫·卡鲁索和我在一家大型投资银行做一些培训。那是在大萧条之前。这家银行后来深受大萧条的影响。参与培训的基本上都是副总裁和高级副总裁，从事银行业务、交易业务、提供投资咨询等工作。其中只有大约10%的人会晋升到他们的最终目标，也就是成为董事总经理，这个职级能拿到丰厚得多的薪酬。所以我们在谈话开始时、在培训刚开始时就会问，
how many of you feel that you are above average in IQ? And every hand would go out. Then we'd say, how many of you feel that you have strong analytic or mathematical or economics skills for your jobs? And every hand would go on? We'd look at them and say, I don't understand. You all are above average in IQ. You all feel you have the analytic and economic,
你们当中有多少人觉得自己智商高于平均水平？所有人都举手了。然后我们会说，你们当中有多少人觉得自己具备胜任工作所需的强大分析能力、数学能力或经济学技能？所有的手又都举起来了。我们看着他们说，我不太明白。你们所有人的智商都高于平均水平。你们都觉得自己拥有分析、经济，
and mathematical skills to do your job. And yet, 90% of you are not going to get to be managing directors. What is that all about? And they would say, well, I guess some people are better able at inspiring others. Some people are better able to manage their own emotions. Some people are better able to manage a group's emotion. Some people are more charismatic. and they'd start to generate what it meant to be an emotionally intelligent person in that context.
以及做好工作的数学技能。然而，你们当中有90%的人无法成为董事总经理。这到底是为什么呢？他们就会说，嗯，我猜有些人更擅长激励他人，有些人更擅长管理自己的情绪，有些人更擅长管理团队的情绪，有些人更有个人魅力。然后他们开始阐述在这种语境下成为一个高情商的人意味着什么。
And recognizing that that was the differentiator, not the analytic skills. Everybody was smart. I understand, Peter, that some research has also employed brain scanning to study the brain activity of people as they solve emotion-related problems. In the study that you're referring to, we ask people to solve problems that were social in nature, problems about conflict with others and the like. And maybe the most important aspect of that work
并认识到这才是区分平庸与卓越的关键，而不是分析技能。每个人都很聪明。我了解到，彼得，一些研究还利用脑成像技术来研究人们在解决与情绪相关的问题时的脑部活动。在你提到的这项研究中，我们让人们解决具有社交性质的问题，比如与他人冲突之类的问题。这项工作或许最重要的方面在于，
is it has seriously challenged the idea that cognition and emotion are separate. You can see in fMRI scans that the parts of the brain thought to be involved in emotion and the parts of the brain thought to be involved in thinking, in decision-making, in problem-solving, in creativity, are closely connected, that there's dense and multiple connections among them,
它严重挑战了认知和情绪是相互分离的观点。你可以在功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）扫描中看到，被认为与情绪有关的脑区和被认为与思考、决策、问题解决、创造力有关的脑区是紧密相连的，它们之间存在着密集且多重的连接，
and that when you activate what we would think of as a strictly cognitive activity, you're also activating the emotion side of things. You also can study people with different kinds of brain damage, People who've had strokes, for example. And if those strokes affect the emotional parts of the brain, they also have an impact on their thinking. Emotions provide us with useful information, crucial data points that we can use
而且当你激活我们认为是纯粹的认知活动时，你同时也在激活情绪的那一侧。你还可以研究患有不同类型脑损伤的人，例如中风患者。如果这些中风影响了大脑的情绪区域，它们也会对他们的思维产生影响。情绪为我们提供了有用的信息，这是我们可以用来
to inform our responses and our decisions. Yet people vary widely in their ability to identify, understand, and manage emotional signals. Is this capacity innate and fixed or an ability we can cultivate? When we come back, how to sharpen our emotional intelligence. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant.
指导我们反应和决策的关键数据点。然而，人们在识别、理解和管理情绪信号的能力上存在很大差异。这种能力是天生且固定的，还是我们可以培养的能力？休息一下，马上回来探讨如何磨炼我们的情商。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹坦。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹坦。
Have you had times in your life when you, you, or someone you know, handled a situation with exquisite emotional intelligence? Or can you think of a moment when you were, well, an emotional idiot? If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with a hidden brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, emotional intelligence.
在你的生活中，有没有遇到过你、你认识的某人或其他人以极其惊人的高情商处理某个情况的时刻？或者你能想起某个时候，你表现得像个“情绪白痴”？如果你有一个愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的个人故事，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将文件发送电子邮件至 Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请写：情商。
Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Peter Salivay is a psychologist at Yale University. He studies how our emotions shape our decisions and our behavior. Peter, researchers have developed a program intended to help people increase their emotional intelligence. It's called Ruler. I understand this is an acronym. What does it stand for?
再重复一遍，邮箱是 Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org。彼得·萨洛维是耶鲁大学的心理学家。他研究我们的情绪如何塑造我们的决定和行为。彼得，研究人员已经开发了一个旨在帮助人们提高情商的项目。它叫 Ruler。我了解到这是一个首字母缩写词。它代表什么意思？
So Ruler is an acronym developed by Mark Brackett, who's a professor here at Yale in the Child Study Center, happened to have been my postdoc and my collaborator, Jack Mayer's graduate student years and years ago. And Ruler is an acronym for the skills that he and his colleagues teach kids from kindergarten through high school to become more emotional, intelligent human beings. The first R is recognizing emotion, the ability to know what you're feeling, know what another person is feeling, to recognize emotions through nonverbal cues or verbal ones.
所以 Ruler 是由马克·布拉克特开发的一个首字母缩写词，他是耶鲁大学儿童研究中心的教授，当年曾是我的博士后，也是我的合作者杰克·迈尔很多年前的学生。Ruler 是他和同事们用来教导从幼儿园到高中的孩子成为更具情商的人所需的各项技能的首字母缩写。第一个 R 是识别情绪（Recognizing emotion），即了解自己正在感受什么、了解另一个人正在感受什么、通过非语言或语言线索来识别情绪的能力。
The U is understanding emotion. What does this emotion mean? How does it transition in time? How does it progress? How do small emotions like irritation turn into big ones like rage? How does it affect our thinking and our behavior? What does it motivate us to do? The L is labeling emotions.
U 代表理解情绪（Understanding emotion）。这种情绪意味着什么？它在时间上是如何转变的？它是如何发展的？像恼怒这样的小情绪是如何变成像暴怒这样的大情绪的？它如何影响我们的思维和行为？它激励我们去做什么？L 代表给情绪命名（Labeling emotions）。
Can I use words to describe this emotion to others? Can I reflect someone's feeling back to them using words? Can I identify where emotion words might fit into an emotion space defined by pleasant and unpleasant dimension and an active versus calm dimension. Most emotions and feeling states can be mapped onto those dimensions. The E is expressing emotion. What am I showing on my face when I express an emotion? How do I modulate those expressions when I am in different settings at work versus at home, at a funeral versus at a party. Am I aware of cultural differences
我能用词语向他人描述这种情绪吗？我能用词语向某人反馈他们的感受吗？我能找出情绪词汇如何契合由愉悦与不愉快维度以及活跃与平静维度所定义的情绪空间吗？大多数情绪和感受状态都可以映射到这些维度上。第二个 E 代表表达情绪（Expressing emotion）。当我表达情绪时，我的面部表现出什么？当我身处不同环境（在工作时与在家时、在葬礼上与在派对上）时，我如何调节这些表情？我是否意识到文化差异
in the way emotions are expressed? It's another part of all of this. Do I understand that in certain cultures, weeping openly is perfectly acceptable and in others a more stoic attitude is expected or that expressing great joy at one's accomplishment might be perfectly acceptable in America, but a little embarrassing in a place like Japan.
在情绪表达方式上的存在？这是这一切的另一个部分。我是否理解，在某些文化中，公开哭泣是完全可以接受的，而在另一些文化中则期望采取更斯多葛的态度；或者在某个人的成就面前表现出巨大的喜悦在美利坚合众国可能是完全可以接受的，但在日本这样的地方可能会稍微有点尴尬。
The final art is regulating emotion, and this is the area of emotional intelligence that has received the most research attention. A wonderful researcher named James Gross, for example, at Stanford University, who is studying the way in which we manage our emotions. primarily through cognition for decades and decades. And regulating our emotion, we need to remember,
最后一个 R 是调节情绪（Regulating emotion），这是情商领域中获得最多研究关注的部分。例如，斯坦福大学一位杰出的研究员詹姆斯·格罗斯，几十年来一直在研究我们如何管理情绪，
we're regulating our emotion, but we also want to regulate the emotions of others sometimes. Why might I want to cheer myself up? Well, perhaps because I'm going to do something creative. Why might I want to calm myself down? I actually feel less happy. Well, because I might have a task in front of me where I need to be vigilant and careful and slow.
主要通过认知手段进行管理。在调节情绪方面，我们需要记住，我们在调节自己的情绪，但有时我们也希望调节他人的情绪。我为什么可能想要让自己振作起来？嗯，也许是因为我要去做一些具有创造性的事情。我为什么可能想要让自己平静下来？我其实感觉没那么快乐。嗯，因为我面前可能有一个任务，需要我保持警惕、小心谨慎并且动作缓慢，
For example, proofreading a manuscript. What about others? When I give a talk, why might I want to tell a joke at the beginning of that talk to manage other people's, regulate other people's emotions before they have to listen to me. So, uh, ruler is recognizing, understanding, labeling, expressing, and regulating. and it forms five kinds of skills that you might want to teach to school children as they learn about their emotions. And it more or less maps onto the four domains that the mesquite,
例如，校对一份手稿。那么其他人呢？当我发表演讲时，我为什么可能想在演讲开始时讲个笑话，以便在他们不得不听我讲话之前管理其他人的情绪、调节其他人的情绪？所以，嗯，Ruler 是识别（Recognizing）、理解（Understanding）、给情绪命名（Labeling）、表达（Expressing）和调节（Regulating）。它构成了五种技能，你可以在学龄儿童了解自己的情绪时教给他们。它或多或少对应着 Mesquite 所测量的四个领域，
which is our ability-based emotion test, measures. We organize them slightly differently than Ruler, but you can see the overlap very clearly. I understand that when people ask you how they might, improve their own emotional intelligence, you have a couple of practical suggestions for them, and one sounds like advice from an English teacher, which is to read good literature. Why would reading help us increase our emotional intelligence, Peter? Well, it is an interesting question, because one of the things we know is that your emotional
也就是我们的基于能力的测评。我们对它们的组织方式与 Ruler 略有不同，但你可以非常清晰地看到它们之间的重叠。我了解到，当人们问你如何能够提高他们自己的情商时，你对他们有一些切实可行的建议，其中一个听起来像是英语老师给出的建议，那就是阅读优秀的文学作品。为什么阅读能帮助我们提高情商呢，彼得？嗯，这是一个有趣的问题，因为我们所了解的事情之一是，你的情感
intelligence can be improved. It's one of the reasons people love the concept of emotional intelligence is because, unlike IQ, which is kind of difficult to change very much after you're a teenager, you can improve your emotional intelligence over the course of your lifetime. Merely aging and gaining life experience typically improves your emotional intelligence. Kind of amazing that way. Now, the difference in terms of how we would go about improving our intelligence, our emotional intelligence, concerns whether we're talking about kids or adults,
智力是可以提高的。人们热爱“情商”这个概念的原因之一，是因为与智商（在青少年之后很难有太大改变）不同，情商可以在你的一生中不断提升。随着年龄的增长和生活经验的积累，你的情商通常也会随之提高。从这个角度来看，这真是相当神奇。现在，关于我们如何去提升智力与情商，其区别在于我们讨论的是孩子还是成人，
for kids teaching these skills directly in the classroom as part of a social, emotional learning program is probably a pretty effective and efficient way to learn these skills. It's a little more difficult as adults to take a class in emotional intelligence. And so we have to look for other ways to do it. I believe, I don't have a lot of data on which to base this, but I believe that's where the arts can really help us. So imagine that when we're reading great literature and trying to understand the motives of characters and why someone is behaving as they are, why they might behave in ways that look conflicted, all of that helps us develop a more sophisticated understanding of emotions,
对于孩子们来说，在课堂上作为社交情感学习项目的一部分直接教授这些技能，可能是一种相当有效且高效的学习方式。而对于成年人来说，去上情商课则要困难一些。因此，我们必须寻找其他方法来实现这一点。我相信（虽然我没有太多的数据来支持这一点），艺术在这一方面能真正地帮到我们。想象一下，当我们阅读伟大的文学作品，试图理解角色的动机、他们为什么会有某种行为、为什么他们的行为可能会显得充满矛盾时，所有这些都有助于我们对情感形成更深刻的理解，
a greater ability to recognize emotions and label them and maybe even manage them. I think having experiences where you're looking at visual art, looking at, let's say, at paintings in an art museum and reacting to them emotionally might help. In Santander, Spain, there is an entire museum, organized, art museum, organized around the idea of emotions and creativity,
从而具备更强的识别、命名甚至管理情感的能力。我认为，当你欣赏视觉艺术、比如说在艺术博物馆里看画作并在情感上做出反应时，这样的体验可能会有所帮助。在西班牙的桑坦德，有一座完整的博物馆，这是一个围绕着情感与创造力的理念来组织的艺术博物馆，
using the art museum experience to practice your emotions. I think listening to music is a great way to practice feeling emotions that you might not feel that often in the outside world. I particularly like theater. And when I was in high school, I was an actor. And I often think theater is a wonderful way because you're watching behavior to gain a deeper understanding of what it means to feel an emotion and how it's connected to thinking and behavior.
利用艺术博物馆的体验来练习你的情感。我认为听音乐是练习感受那些你在现实世界中可能不常感受到的情感的好方法。我特别喜欢戏剧。当我读高中时，我曾是一名演员。我常常觉得戏剧是一种绝妙的方式，因为你可以通过观察行为来更深入地理解感受某种情感意味着什么，以及它如何与思维和行为相连。
You know, in method acting, one of the techniques you might use to create an emotion is actually to enact the behaviors associated with that emotion, and then that emotion might follow. Act as if crying and crying might follow. Well, having those kind of experiences either as an observer or actually being on stage yourself might help you develop a more sophisticated understanding of how our emotions work and how they're connected to behavior and cognition. You know, I'm thinking about the times when we go to a gym and we start working with, you know, different equipment.
你知道，在方法演技中，你用来产生情感的技术之一，实际上就是去表演与该情感相关的行为，接着那种情感可能会随之而来。表现得像是在哭泣，哭泣可能就会随之发生。嗯，无论作为旁观者还是亲自登上舞台，拥有这些经历都可以帮助你对我们的情感如何运作以及它们如何与行为和认知相连，产生更复杂的理解。你知道，我在想我们去健身房并开始使用各种器械的时候。
And all of a sudden you realize that you had muscles that you didn't know that you had because your body starts to ache and pain in different places. And in some ways, what you're talking about emotions is actually not that different, that in some ways, the more we exercise our emotional repertoire, the more we discover that we have emotional recesses almost, that we haven't really explored, that are worth exploring and strengthening. I think that's exactly right, Chunker. And the more you do it, the better you develop these skills so that empathizing becomes
突然之间你会发现，原来自己身上有一些你根本不知道的肌肉，因为你的身体开始在不同的地方感到酸痛。从某种意义上说，你所讨论的情感其实也差不太多，在某种程度上，我们对情感库的锻炼越多，我们就越会发现自己几乎拥有一些尚未真正探索过的情感深处，而这些深处是值得去探索和加强的。我认为完全是这样，尚卡尔。你做得越多，这些技能就发展得越好，从而使产生同理心变得
natural, so that recognizing emotions in someone who is saying something different than their feeling becomes more second nature. so that you develop over time muscles that allow you to take advantage of the data that is inherent in our emotional system. And it becomes, I don't want to sound too woo-woo here, but it becomes kind of like a sixth sense. Yes, we see and we hear and we taste and we smell and we touch, but we also feel our emotions and maybe there's some data there that is being conveyed to us that we should pay attention to.
自然而然，从而让识别那些言不由衷之人的真实情感变得更像是第二天性。这样，随着时间的推移，你就会锻炼出肌肉，使你能够充分利用我们情感系统中固有的数据。它变得——我不想在这里听起来太玄乎——但它有点像第六感。是的，我们能看到、听到、尝到、闻到、摸到，但我们也能感受到我们的情感，也许其中传递着一些我们应该予以关注的数据。
Why is it that I'm thinking about, well, let's say purchasing a product, but I get a feeling in the pit of my stomach that's a little queasy. Shouldn't I stop and think about why that product made me feel that way? Why is it that I might find myself attracted to another person, and that's accompanied with joy versus it's accompanied by a little bit of worry. What does that tell me? What does that tell me? And so for the most part, people go through life ignoring all of that.
为什么我在考虑，比如说购买一件产品时，胃里却会有一种隐隐作呕、略感不适的感觉？难道我不应该停下来思考一下为什么那件产品会让我有这种感觉吗？为什么我可能会发现自己被另一个人吸引，而这种吸引伴随着喜悦，而不是伴随着一丝担忧？这说明了什么？这说明了什么？因此，大多数人过着生活，却对所有这一切置之不理。
And what I'm suggesting is these are data. And when you ask a friend, let's say, or spouse or family member to roleplay something with you, Tomorrow I'm going to go ask my boss for a raise. When you role play it, you learn how expressing certain words creates certain feelings in you. You learn when your feelings are maybe going to push you in directions you don't want to go. And you can practice modulating those feelings. You can practice regulating them.
而我所建议的是，这些都是数据。比方说，当你请求朋友、配偶或家庭成员与你进行角色扮演时：“明天我要去找老板加薪。”通过角色扮演，你懂得了表达某些话语是如何在你的内心激起特定感受的；你懂得了自己的感受何时可能会推动你走向你不想去方向；你还可以练习调节这些感受，练习控制它们。
You can practice taking a deep breath, pausing, giving yourself a minute to calm. down and then continuing on. Our whole conception of emotional intelligence is that these are skills. You use the metaphor muscle. You can think of these as skills just like an athletic skill where, you know, when you develop those muscles and you take thousands and thousands of foul shots from the basketball foul line, you get better at them. The same is true when you roleplay emotionally evocative situation.
你可以练习深呼吸、停顿、给自己一分钟时间平静下来，然后再继续。我们对情商的整体概念是，这些都是技能。你用了肌肉这个比喻。你可以把这些看作是技能，就像运动技能一样——你知道，当你锻炼了那些肌肉，在篮球罚球线上投了成千上万次罚球后，你的罚球技术就会提高。当你对会唤起情感的情境进行角色扮演时，情况也是如此。
What can I learn from watching the way my body responds, my thoughts change, and my feelings are expressed and have an impact on others? The idea of emotional intelligence isn't new. In fact, you might say it's one of the most popular terms in all of psychology. Managers, parents, teachers all preach the importance of emotional intelligence. Sadly, however, a lot of what you may have heard about this concept, is wrong. In our companion story to this episode, available exclusively to subscribers to Hidden Brain Plus, we explore how the enormous popularity of emotional intelligence has spawned a number of myths and misguided notions.
我能从观察身体的反应方式、思想的变化、情感的表达以及对他人产生的影响中学到什么？情商的概念并不新鲜。事实上，你可能会说它是整个心理学中最受欢迎的概念之一。经理、父母、老师都在宣扬情商的重要性。然而可悲的是，关于这个概念，你所听到的大量内容其实都是错的。在本集的配套故事中（仅向“隐形大脑”Plus订阅者独家提供），我们探讨了情商的巨大受欢迎程度是如何滋生出一系列神话和误解的。
If you're a subscriber, that episode is available right now. It's titled, Emotional Intelligence isn't about being nice. If you're not yet a subscriber, please visit support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.co slash hidden brain. You'll instantly have access to all our subscriber-only content, including past episodes. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org and apple.com slash hidden brain. Peter Salivay is a psychologist at Yale University. Along with Jack Mayer, he helped coin the concept of emotional intelligence.
如果你是订阅者，那一集现在就可以收听。它的标题是：情商不等于做个好人。如果你还不是订阅者，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain。你将立即获得我们所有仅限订阅者阅读的内容，包括往期节目。再说一次，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org 和 apple.com/hiddenbrain。彼得·萨洛维是耶鲁大学的心理学家。他与杰克·迈尔斯一起，共同创立了情商这一概念。
Peter has written and co-written several books about emotional intelligence, including the emotionally intelligent manager how to develop and use the four key emotional skills of leadership. Peter, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shuckers. It was a delight for me, and I very much enjoyed our conversation, and I truly enjoy your show. If you have a personal story about emotional intelligence
彼得已经撰写和合著了几本关于情商的书籍，其中包括《情商管理者：如何培养和运用领导力的四项关键情感技能》。彼得，非常感谢你今天来到“隐形大脑”。谢谢你，尚卡尔。对我来说这是一件乐事，我非常享受我们的交谈，我也真的很喜欢你的节目。如果你有一个关于情商的个人故事，
that you'd be willing to share with a hidden brain audience or a question or comment about the research in this episode, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Then email the file to us at feedback at hiddenbrain.org using the subject line, Emotional Intelligence. Again, that's feedback at hiddenbrain.org.
并且愿意与“隐形大脑”的听众分享，或者对本集的研究有任何疑问或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两到三分钟就足够了。然后将该文件通过电子邮件发送给我们：feedback@hiddenbrain.org，邮件主题请使用“Emotional Intelligence”（情商）。再次说明，邮箱是 feedback@hiddenbrain.org。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Special thanks today to Simon Lindstedt. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
“隐形大脑”由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·克雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、安德鲁·查德里克和尼克·伍德伯里。今天特别感谢西蒙·林德斯特。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐形大脑”的执行主编。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。